all eyes are on chicago tonight as
members of the teachers union vote on
whether or not chicago public schools
will return to remote learning in the
meantime the district is preparing for
the worst
the one thing and we're going to send a
message to parents later this afternoon
about this
i will have to cancel classes tomorrow
it doesn't mean that the schools will be
closed the schools will be open but i
will have to cancel classes tomorrow
because i can't i have to be responsible
not knowing who's going to be showing up
to the buildings
but it's not just chicago several
districts across the nation preparing to
shut down schools once again so why
isn't anyone sticking up for america's
children the data is clear remote
learning and absurd mandates are hurting
our children research shows that the
test scores in reading and math were
significantly lower in 2021 compared to
years past and their mental health is
also declining but when you look at the
numbers it's minority children that are
suffering the most a study by mckenzie
and company shows that students in
majority black schools are six months
behind in reading and math as a result
of the pandemic while students the
majority white schools were just three
to four months behind still bad
these kids are hurting but yet no one is
doing a thing about it where are the
democrats and where are the republicans
joining me now
host of did she say that podcast sunny
johnson so
sonny i expect democrats to do nothing
they have been in bed with the teachers
unions for years
but it is frustrating when republicans
run on helping the kids and do nothing
as well
i was sitting here i was like it's going
to be interesting how you phrased this
question because as soon as i heard the
topic the one thing that i started to
think about was the life of julia if you
remember what this it was this was a
theory program put out under the barack
obama administration where it mapped how
government would interfere in your life
from the time you were born until the
time you died basically showing how
every single step of the of your life
every stage of your life government has
a role in
to play in that stage and i think that
that's where we're what we're seeing um
now play out and come to fruition if you
don't send your kids to some form or
school mostly public schools there are
laws against you that can be used
against to punish you truancy laws so
they make it so you have no choice by
force to send your children to these
institutions if you can't afford other
options you are forced to send your kids
and if you become accustomed to it you
become it becomes regulated towards you
and now what we're seeing is how much
power government has when they provide
you with everything to take everything
away so now that they have taken
especially the uh the kids that are at
the lower socio echo socioeconomic scale
and said um we're going to give you
school
now we're going to take it away you're
going to see how much ability government
has to interfere with our lives but not
only that it also exposed a lot of of
what wrong has been done in the public
school systems if you remember at the
beginning of the epidemic
one of the biggest things that you had
progressives and democrats complaining
about was now they weren't going to be
able to distribute food like they had
done before because now schools have
come up become a platform where they're
able to feed the poor through the school
system now it's nothing wrong with
feeding the poor but is that why we set
up the school system so a lot of what
they have been doing to entrench
themselves into our lives has now been
exposed by the mandates that they are
pushing um especially uh when it comes
to to covet and the reason you don't
have republicans fighting back is
because they can't because majority of
these regulations and rules that are
coming through are on the local level
there are no republicans at the local
level with the power or the capacity to
actually fight back um against these
policies so there is nothing that the
republicans do can do there is no
solution for republicans as long as
their strategy for these areas is to run
with their tail tuck between their legs
so as a result of republicans not
running for those mayor and city council
and school board races they have zero
control of what's happening right now
and they wonder why and they put it on
black america like okay black america
hates conservative policies we don't
ever get offered them you think that if
you were really in chicago right now
saying hey look how the school system
treats you we have a better way let us
show you how this works let us show you
how you can get back uh your freedom and
your liberty to provide a quality
education for your child but not to be
subject to the whims of government and
this is what we are seeing the more
power we give government the more they
are going to use that power to crush us
when available and people need to be
very very very cautious about this
especially when you're looking at like
the build back better plan and the um
aspect they have in it for the free
pre-k that pre-k is government pre-k
they're not going to be giving those
grants to private institutions or or
your religious institutions if you're
going to want to benefit from um the
candy jar of government you're going to
have to send your kids to government
schools that are going to be run by
karen's who have women's study degrees
who have put off raising their own
children for a chance to raise yours
that is what we are looking at and we
need to be taking it seriously and if
republicans will not decide that the
local level is where the real fight is
there is nothing that they can offer to
black america or to america's children
wow
sonny johnson sirius xm patron thank you
so much for joining the program
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else